does a movie start with an idea or does
it start with an
audience depends who you ask
um i would say an idea
and then the and then you would gauge
whether there's an audience for that
idea
um but if you do have an audience
and you want to cater to that audience
and there's demand
then you create an idea to cater to it
not unlike a product
right let's say that uh
then again let's use apple as an example
okay
you know the founders of apple said hey
the computer market is new and we need
something that's super user friendly
that's what the audience the consumers
want they want super super friendly
so then they create i think then they
create a product to cater to that demand
as opposed to hey we're going to make a
super well might
i guess it could go either way we're
going to make a super friendly
user-friendly computer and we
suspect that the consuming base will
really love it
so it i guess they could go either way
whereas you know with the
case of a movie generally independent
films start with an idea
because independent filmmakers are
artists and they want to express their
artistic you know sensitivities and that
type of thing so
they'll say this is what i want to do
and i'll make a movie to do it
and unfortunately not enough of them
think about who the audience is going to
be afterwards
and then it's really hard to get to that
audience i would think studios though
would say hey
feels like like we talked about before
there's some trending going on in you
know horror films or sci-fi's and
so let's let's get some sci-fi ideas in
here let's make a couple more of those
because it feels like that's the way the
market's going to go for a bit
and then when the idea has
brought such an audience hence sequels
happen
and then it almost seems like the
original idea
gets cheapened in a sense toward the end
of the sequel run
maybe i'm wrong how does that happen how
does this precious idea
that garnered this audience then through
many
iterations become it's like okay i think
they
they they i don't want to say beat a
dead horse but you know in that and that
they they took too long with it or
there's too many
they tried too hard and it ruined that
original
concept maybe not sequels are are
you know a component of marketing i mean
when something works
why not capitalize on it and make some
more money off of it so
hence a sequel that's what it is i mean
you know you have a product that is
working really well bring out the second
edition of it you know
iphone worked well bring out iphone two
bring out iphone three bring out iphone
four
why not you got the market they want
more better
greater just keep giving it to them in
the case of a sequel
in movies um you use the word cheapen
i could give you lots of examples where
the sequel is actually better than the
original one
and i would say that you know empire
strikes back with star wars was a better
movie than star
wars it needed star wars to get it going
but that was a far more entertaining
movie
and that's because now the concept was
proven and
studio was prepared to spend more money
and maybe give a little more creative
control to the producers and directors
and that type of thing so hence they had
more resources to make a better movie
but you are right in a lot of cases it
becomes cheaper because they're just
trying to
capitalize on you know a trend that they
built and it just throwed out their
similar style and and not really think
about it as much and it's not
as artistic but the bottom line is they
work
i mean statistically if you look at the
numbers and the economics behind it
sequels generate a lot of money and and
you know
maybe not as much as the first one maybe
sometimes more
i mean look at the rocky franchise they
just kept being bigger and bigger and
bigger those movies
so why not it's the same story you tell
it over a few times but it's a good
story
and people like it so if you get people
invested in the characters and the idea
and you take them on that ride and it
works sometimes then
it's not always about it doesn't always
cheapen it it's about the audience i
mean if you're focused on the audience
and
the audience is enjoying it and that's
what they want then i wouldn't use the
word cheap in it
it's you're just giving them more of
what they want artistically you know if
you're talking about an artist an artist
might say
you've compromised your artistic
integrity by you know just copying the
same thing over and over and over and
that would be correct but for the
studios it's primarily about
profit so why not get more of the same
they're predictable and do you think
that studios bank on the fact that the
audience will age
and they can go along with these sequels
or they know that they're going to be
new audiences cropping up
the the descendants of the original
audience well i mean it's funny i just
mentioned rocky because that's a perfect
example of what you're talking about
because they they that thing was the
five rocky movies and then
you know years later they come up with
creed
and creed is you know apollo creed the
character from the first movie his son
now they have a whole new line of movies
based on that
so would you call that a sequel or what
would that be
it's an ancillary product that came out
of a very successful franchise
and so they're creating a second
franchise out of a first franchise which
i think is super smart
and you know like so we grew up with
rocky right um i don't enjoy the creed
movies as much as the rocky movies but
my kids do
my kids like them way better because
that's the new hero
you know the the he's younger he's
got a certain personality that they
relate to more than you know than rocky
sure times change yeah so do i
necessarily does it cater to me no but
but it caters to a younger audience that
you know
sort of capitalizes on the same thing
that they capitalize on
us with rocky sure and it works well
what do you think about the sentence
don't write for the market
i'm not a typical filmmaker i come from
the business side of the filmmaking
industry like
i told you i didn't go to film school i
went to
business school and law school so um and
i wouldn't i'm
not going to say that i'm not artistic
because i am and i really really care
about the creative process and the
artistic integrity that
very very much so because you don't want
to cheapen the product and
i take a lot of pride in the stuff that
i do
but don't write for the audience like
who you're writing for if it's not for
the audience if it's for your
i mean yeah if you want to write for
yourself no problem but if you want your
movies to be successful and you want
you know to make a career out of it and
and you know and be
financially comfortable you got to
consider the audience
i mean they're the people paying for it
to consume it
again if you have the luxury of not
worrying about that and not having to
make a living from it
then write for whoever you want right
for yourself but if you
have to make a living from your audience
because you want them to pay to consume
your product
you better cater to them what about the
purists
though that feel that
their creation is is and i'm i'm using
cheap and too much i'm going to try to
find a new word but
that it's being compromised oh
compromise i like that yeah it's good
compromise and and and changed by too
many hands
then maybe is is just making films
for those that were so precious about
their ideas and they don't want too many
you know whether it's a test audience um
you know
exchange this part here that maybe that
is just best to make the film
in the sense the way you made your first
film uh with your grandfather's story
that it was something that you needed to
do and you really felt felt contentment
after you finished it
but you weren't there to try to sell it
in terms of it wasn't supposed to be
this million dollar idea right
and and that there are two kinds of
filmmakers and that that's okay
yeah it's definitely okay but um again
it depends what
financial comfort and luxury you have in
your life
if you're doing this to make a living
then you have to focus on the audience
if you're if you don't it's not about
making a living but it's it's an
artistic endeavor
that's either a hobby or something that
it's not going to
change your life and you don't need it
to make income
then yeah you have to do whatever you
want to do but here's the advice i would
definitely give to independent
filmmakers
if you really have a message and and you
do have to make a living from it
but you really want to maintain that
artistic integrity which i
highly recommend you do write a book
don't make a movie a book is so much
cheaper
to write and to publish than it is to
make a movie
so why put yourself in that financial
predicament of making a movie
just write a book and and express
yourself exactly the way you want it to
and you'll have it forever and the world
will have it
and maybe you'll make a movie someday of
it um now
there are filmmakers who do have the
luxury either by
happenstance or like coincidence or
or they were born into it or whatever
have the luxury of doing whatever they
want to do
which is fantastic and when they do that
um sometimes it's absolutely brilliant
when they have no financial you know
considerations or no directions or
whatever they get to do what they want
to do
it doesn't happen often but you know it
does happen after you've had a lot of
success like like tarantino nobody's
going to tell him how to make a movie
anymore
and i'm not sure maybe the studios
didn't tell him at the beginning but
um when you have that proven success
and people you know are willing to bank
on your raw talent
that's great but usually out of the gate
with
independent filmmakers i mean a lot of
them do have that great raw talent
and and can hit a home run the first
time around but people don't know it
and it's it's super risky so making a
a movie and i'm talk when i say make a
movie i'm not talking you know fifty
thousand or hundred thousand i'm talking
you know
eight hundred thousand nine hundred
million dollars or whatever there's real
money involved
and somebody's gonna lose a lot of money
and if they can afford to and they say
no problem
no problem great that's fantastic but if
there's fina if people's you know
financial comfort is at stake
i say the audience says you got to
really keep that in consideration
you know you brought up book and forgive
me i'm reading this book about jd
salinger right now
and this woman who had a job at an
agency answering his fan mail
and to see that his fan mail spanned
generations
and it was so it was so much that they
couldn't even give it to him
he had to he he had sort of a shield up
because he had created something that
resonated with so many generations of
people
and that's something he probably didn't
intend on having happen he wrote it sort
of out of his own angst and
being in the war and different things
like that but that's one example of of
probably not intending to write for a
market but somehow
it was lightning in a bottle how rare is
that
i don't know for sure because i would
say most independent writers and produce
and and directors and you know do right
for what the artistic merit of it they
have something that they want to express
and
and they just write it so i did that
i mean that's what i did with my first
movie i wrote the script the way i
wanted it
i didn't have to answer to any studio
exactly i just had to answer to myself
i did it how i wanted to now if i were
to do it again do a
remake of it i would probably do it a
little differently i would make it more
audience friendly
i would make that i would pace it a
little differently i would cut it a
little differently i would
make it you know a little bit more
audience friendly because
the audience now i understand the
audience better
my brother's keeper sorry yeah my
brother's keepers i was to make that
again
so you know the first time around you
tend to believe that what you're going
to make
is going to be so artistically sound
that it will resonate with audiences
and you don't really have to pay
attention to them you just have to be
as creative as and you know as possible
um and and it does work sometimes it
does but there
are some trends and some you know things
that people have learned along the way
that also work that would be good to
take into consideration
but it you know artists could say that
that is a compromise
but do you think that that's good that
you had that experience and that you
knew
a story you had to get out there for
your own personal reasons
and now you can resonate with a lot of
filmmakers who you probably have to have
that talk with them
because they they it's they're precious
with their idea
but you also know that they need to sell
certain territories and that might not
work in a territory yeah
remember i had the like i said you know
the financial luxury of owning my own
business
and being financially comfortable so i
wouldn't have i
also had four kids so i would not have
done that had i not had financial
comfort
behind me it it wasn't going to change
my lifestyle
but if it was if i i wasn't going to
prepare listen
i had a dream and i wanted to live it
but i wasn't prepared to
roll the dice on the rest of my life on
my own family and my house and
everything like that and that's still
more important to me
so um i guess i'm just that kind of guy
i'm super responsible that way and i
like to
find the balance of living my dreams and
how and one of my dreams is having a
nice family and a nice
family life right so you got to keep
that in balance
um if you have that in your life then do
what you need to do
like just do it your way
stay the vision do it exactly how you
want to do it and so because at the end
of the day
i mean two things are going to happen
one is it's either going to be
financially successful or not
but the at the end of the day what is
most important is
when you look back on that that's your
legacy in your life
you have to feel really good you can't
second-guess yourself for the rest of
your life saying oh if i would have
stuck to my vision or if i would have
done this or i would have done that
and you have to say this is what i
wanted to do in my life this is why i'm
doing it
this is my dream i'm sacrificing so much
else i want to
keep the artistic integrity because
that's what i want to do that's the
message i want to do
so i strongly strongly encourage that
it's not you see it's the question is
what is a compromise everybody has a
different level where they draw that
line right so for me if you know if
here's 100
if i compromise 20 and i keep the other
intact i feel okay i feel that that
wasn't too big of a compromise because
i know why i did that i'm going after a
certain audience and i need to pace it
differently or i need to add a subplot
in or i need to do something that i
wouldn't otherwise do artistically
i don't like i'm never going to regret
that decision because
i have that financial business side of
me saying i know why i did it
i did it because i wanted to try to to
reach the audience
but if you're an artist who that will
bother you the rest of your life then
don't do it
don't do it and hope that what you've
done will resonate with your audience
because then they never know for sure
you can follow patterns but they're
nothing's for sure for sure it's not set
in stone
sure and and some people live by
this motto that they don't want to be a
sellout
i know it gets a lot of i mean that
spans generations to sell it whether
it's in music
um you know writing uh film but some
people you said
being okay with that 20 some people
might consider that 20
selling out oh 100 totally i mean some
people might consider one percent
selling out
and so you have to know who you are and
you got to feel confident
like i said when all is said and done i
mean the litmus test the true litmus
test is
five years later how do you feel about
what you did
not two months later not six months
later because you know you're going
through
let it sit and five years later come
back to it watch it again
how do you feel about it do you feel
like you sold out do you feel
that you made a mistake that you did
something wrong
that's about knowing yourself and
everybody has a different
sort of level at which they deal with um
so
i would never sell myself out like
here's the here's the classic example of
that as a studio or or you know a
distributor some
some corporation the film industry says
wow we read your script and we like it
and we want to make it but we don't want
you to direct it we want to put another
director on
and that other director is going to have
artistic um
you know decision making on it that
is tricky right because you want your
movie made you want your story being
told you wrote your script you love it
but nine times out of ten they're not
gonna tell it the way you told it
and then sometimes they might tell it
better but usually you're gonna feel
compromise
so is that a compromise that's worth
doing i mean here
on the one side you're getting your
movie made it's a dream your script
you're getting paid for it
you're gonna see it come to life but on
the other side you don't get to
to it's like having a baby and giving
that baby to someone else to raise it so
you love the baby you're always going to
love the baby
but you don't like the direction they
raised it
is that a compromise depends who you are
and depends what you feel if you feel
it's a compromise then don't do it
if you feel it's not then do it and it's
it's all per
it's very personal decision
you